beef tacos with wasabi mayo
the great thing about street food is
anything goes the only rule is they've
got to be really fast and really tasty
now these tacos mix a mexican and
japanese flavors into a delicious meaty
mouthful
first off get that pan really nice and
hot
these are
sirloin steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
they'll add flavour
salt and pepper
couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan
nice and hot
hold up the steak
and lay it in always lay away
give the panna
a little shake and it stops the steak
from sticking we're looking for color
and if it sticks it's gonna burn
[Music]
while the steaks are cooking i can get
on with my super quick marinade
now
two tablespoons of
misood paste that's a fermented soy bean
that gives a really nice sort of rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar
a couple of tablespoons rice wine that
gives it a really nice vinegary
kick a couple of tablespoons of olive
oil
salt and pepper
i'm looking for a nice sort of thick
rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
sort the pan
and to give the steaks a little base all
we're doing every time is just adding
more more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really
melt all that fat down
offer the gas
take them out
just take your knife
see all that fat there just slice that
off
i don't want any of that
now in
to the marinade
[Music]
beautiful
tacos are one of mexico's most popular
street foods they've been made from beef
pork chicken or fish and are loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now i want something sort of pickly
cabbage
these are
um chinese cabbages slice it in half
look at it really crisp and really tasty
we're gonna slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
you think of cabbage here and you think
you're sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but at a taco you want freshness
a little season of chili flakes
they sort of discreetly
give it a little bit of heat
a little touch
of rice wine vinegar
if you haven't got that fresh lemon
juice
a small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that
a really good mix
now i need something to sort of bring it
together we take some wasabi paste very
hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail size
i'm gonna mix that
with a couple of tablespoons of
mayonnaise
and give that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them
actually place it
on
the gas ring
use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan
from there
i'm just going to place it
on the rolling pin
literally 30 seconds
as it cools down
the great thing about serving tacos is
people can fill them themselves just the
way they want them cabbage
just squeeze out wet marinade
nice
rustic little mountain
mayonnaise
on
wait you see
how soft
and delicious and almost sort of
melting in the mouth texture we've got
on this amazing sirloin
it's got that really nice
sear around the outside
it's just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my
crispy shell
back of the spoon with the wasabi
mayonnaise
inside taco
and just sprinkle
that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just
start lining my taco three or four
slices
touch more
on my spicy
mayo
and that is how i'd make
the perfect taco
[Music]
malt chocolate donuts street food is all
about satisfying your cravings these
donuts are sweet sticky and absolutely
delicious
first off we're gonna make the dough
now
this dough takes a bit of time but it's
really exciting
i'm heating all of the milk with the
sugar
this yeast
easy to get hold of now when you make
fresh donuts
you need fresh yeast
adding some of the warm milk to the
yeast will activate it which will help
the dough to rise
just half
give that a quick whisk
the sugar is dissolved in the milk
the fresh yeast disintegrates instantly
set the yeast mixture to one side while
it does its job
to start the main dough mix i'm adding
half the butter to the remaining milk
that gives the dough a nice silkiness i
want it light
so melt the butter into the milk
flour
into a sieve that helps to make the
dough nice and smooth and you know what
when you've got a smooth dough
it sort of rises evenly
add a pinch of salt and two egg yolks
pour in the warm milk and melted butter
don't start over mixing it
when you over mix
the dough of the doughnut it gets really
tight you're not gonna let it ariel
yeast in
nice and warm
i love that smell
now i'm looking for a sort of elasticy
texture just dropping off the spoon
nice flour the board
take the dough out
lovely
lightly sprinkle touch more flour and
just pull it over and push in
every time you're sort of turning it
almost like you're turning the dough
into itself the dough should just sort
of relax
it shouldn't be sticking to your fingers
now it's just nice and pliable
set that in a nice clean bowl
a little sprinkling a flour in there so
as it starts to rise it doesn't stick
cover that with some film
leave the dough to rise in a warm place
for 60 to 90 minutes until it's doubled
in size this stage is called proving
now whilst that's proving get a panel
for the chocolate filling or ganache
pour 500 ml of double cream into a
saucepan and add honey
[Music]
bring the mixture to a gentle boil
[Music]
traditionally we've always put jam in
there but chocolate and donuts wow to
die for
add the cream
i'll give that a good mix
the butter elevates the ganache into a
really nice
shiny chocolate coat
look at that whoa
give it a really nice whisk
the whistling gives it that aerated
texture to the ganache you're just
lightening the load a little bit
nice
chocolate filling done
put it in the fridge to cool then it's
time to gently roll out the dough
just let it roll naturally
a centimeter and a half in depth
slice
one
two
place them on to your tray
and let them rise again
once the donors have had 30 to 40
minutes to rise it's time to shallow fry
them in a pan filled one third full with
hot vegetable oil
risen but look they're sort of
like little pockets of air
right here we go
place these in nice and carefully
four maximum if there's too many in the
pan the oil will go cold and the donuts
will come out soggy
turn them over
beautiful
[Music]
they're going to come out into some
sugar mixed with some malt powder 50 50.
how do you tell they're actually cooked
in the center
tap on top it should be hollow
in
and just sprinkle
the malt
and the sugar
shake off
the excess i get so excited every time i
make donuts
now
look at those beauties
these are delicious eating as they are
but the ganache is gonna be the icing on
the cake
piping bag
peel the bag over your hand
don't forget to pop the nozzle in
i want the texture
almost like a little liquid inside
so i'm going to pipe them in a little
bit warm hopefully you've got that burst
of magic
operation donut
lift up
the donut
squeeze push in and fill
just to start seeing that chocolate
coming out
and sit that back down
nice
sit them on there
they've got a little bit heavier and we
all know why
nice
that one's got my name on it
that is amazing
[Music]
slow cooking is one of the best weapons
in the chef's arsenal not only is it
easy it's also an incredible way to
transform meat into mouth-wateringly
melting dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn
first up my phenomenal slow cooked beef
short ribs
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones
across there
and as the short rib cooks it sticks to
that bone the bone implants flavor and
the meat just sort of melts cooks slowly
gives it that nice level intensity slice
alongside the bone straight down you can
see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates i'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot
season these short ribs beautifully
olive oil in bone on the top
we'll start coloring that in
really important to give the beef short
rib a really nice sear
if you didn't brown the meat off
it goes in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that nice dark rich coloring
just cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef an amazing
flavor
[Music]
to give body to the sauce stir in a
heaped teaspoon of tomato puree
i'm just hitting the bottom of the pan
with that tomato puree
and we call it cooking out that smell of
puree
otherwise it just goes in there raw and
it gives this sort of tartness to the
braised short ribs
red wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor it makes a big
difference when you reduce the red wine
down by half because it gives that nice
dark rich
intensity
look at my garlic
that is just gonna sweeten everything up
incredible
stock in
beef stock perfect chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bring it up to the ball
to lock in all that flavor as the beef
ribs slow cook cover them so they braise
from the bottom and steam from the top
into the oven two and a half hours
170 to 180 degrees
she goes
the great thing about slow cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish this is light cured
pancetta
i want nice thick
lardons
nice big thick sticks of crispy bacon
[Music]
these are delicious chestnut mushrooms
i'm not gonna slice them i'm just going
to cut them in half
but look at the color on those lardons
now
all the whites raw fat have disappeared
the lardons have shrunk
right down
and all we've got there now is the
proper bacon
mushrooms in
beautiful
so the mushrooms get seasoned from the
bacon
i'm pan frying these separately to the
beef so they remain crisp and have a
different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down
now
this is like christmas day for me when
you unwrap that fall wait you see what's
underneath it
[Music]
wow
they smell
incredible
lift and place
on the tray
beautiful
to make a fantastic rich deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices
all that nice pureed garlic coming
through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing flavor
scrape
all of that
off the sieve
nice
then just start
sieving all that lovely braising liquor
wow
in
that smells delicious
take your sauce
and just glaze
do them individually
they deserve that respect
spoon on
your bacon
and your mushrooms
[Music]
beautiful
be generous with these mushrooms i'm
telling you
they taste amazing
flat leaf parsley all that freshness
over those amazing ribs incredible never
ever be embarrassed about going to your
butcher and asking for cheap cuts
because the results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs with bacon and mushrooms